My name is Vishal Makhijani.
I'm the President and
Chief Operating Officer here at Udacity.
I have one big job and that's to
help our folks help our students.
I think what students always have to
remember is they have to be the best
salesperson possible for their idea.
And what that means is being able
to crisply articulate exactly what
their idea is in a few short sentences.
It's important not to get
too lost in the details.
It's important to really understand
what your idea is about and
be able to tell anyone who wants to know
exactly what your idea is all about.
Like anything else that's important,
practice is really important.
Try it out, try it out on your friends,
try it on your parents,
try it out on your colleagues.
Try it out on anyone that will listen,
in fact.
Don't be worried about sounding foolish.
Keep continue to work on that really
crisp pitch of what your idea
is all about with any and
all who will listen to it.
Don't worry about giving that
idea away or any secrecy.
The better you get at talking about
your idea in a way that excites and
engages people,
the better opportunity you have to build
that great thing that you want to build.